I'm going to show you how one secret
society pretending to follow Christ
deceived nearly all of Christianity.
When Bible prophecy exposed a certain
power as the Antichrist, they didn't
only deny it, they struck back. They
sent their own secret society members,
the Jesuits, disguised as Protestants
and even Jews, to twist the truth and
point people somewhere else. And almost
everyone even today took the bait. Now
real quick, we are discussing a
religious entity, not genuine loving
followers of Jesus who are part of it.
This is not an attack on them. We love
and respect them. We are just discussing
a false system of worship as described
in Bible prophecy. So system not the
people. Okay, let's dive in. So how did
they try and shift the blame away from
the Catholic Church? So Rome had to
counter the Protestant Reformation that
was really beginning to expose her. And
one of the things that she did to do
that was, you know, at the fifth Lateran
Council, December 1516, there was
actually a prohibition against studying
when Antichrist was going to come forth.
They actually prohibited studying the
signs or seasons for the judgment and
for the antichrist and uh when the
antichrist would come. But really what
we see with the Jesuits is in the
counterreformation we see two splits
occurring. We have uh Alcazar
introducing predism and then we have
Rbera and Lacunza introducing futurism.
And I want to show you what this did
here to the understanding of uh of the
antichrist power and the 1260 years that
were mentioned in Bible prophecy.
Historicism had identified those 1260
years as the dark ages uh to the French
Revolution from 538 to 1798 really
beginning with Justinian's CEX declaring
the pope head of all the churches and
Napoleon's CEX coming along and ending
papal supremacy. But Rome said nope
we're going to go ahead and outlaw that
and say that's not correct. We need to
discourage that kind of thinking. We're
going to introduce either predism
through Alcazar or we're going to
introduce futurism through lacuna. Now
purerism looked at revelation chapters
1-1 and described it as the Jews and the
destruction of Jerusalem by the Romans
and really focusing on pagan Rome. So
Antichrist is identified as Caesar,
Nero, and the judgment period. All those
prophecies occurred thousands of years
ago. It's all deep in the past. Now Rome
doesn't care which side you buy. You can
either buy predism or futurism so long
as you take the focus off her. She
doesn't care. And so there's many people
today who take either side. But you have
Roberta right here who was a Jesuit
doctor of theology and introduced this
idea that the antichrist, a single
individual, would persecute and blasphe
the saints of God, rebuild the temple in
Jerusalem, abolish the Christian
religion, deny Jesus Christ, be received
by the Jews, pretend to be God, kill the
two witnesses of God, and conquer the
world. It sounds very similar to what
evangelicals teach today. There's good
reason for that because they bought this
idea from Rome. Manuel Lacuna wrote this
book called Venita de Messias in Gloria
Imagistad. And you can see right there
compto uh Juan Yosephet Benzra. He
actually wrote it under the pen name of
Rabbi Ben Ezra. And so to kind of better
better mask and better shield himself,
he wrote it under a pen name of a Jew.
Wait, wait. So So basically this was a
Jesuit. Uhhuh. Who we talked about
Jesuits were trying to infiltrate with
Protestant churches. They're not saying,
"I'm a
Jesuit, everybody. I'm a Roman Catholic.
I've come to do this." They're like, "I
am a Protestant." Right. It's cloak and
dagger. It is. So so so interesting.
Scotty who who you know is one of our
team members. He once went to a church,
Protestant church, Christian church. It
was in his younger years. We just
started coming back to Christianity and
he was in the services and and somebody
was hired on. I think it was a youth
pastor or like an associate pastor and
he started noticing the services started
to change. It started getting more
rowdy, more loud and the Bible was more
set to the side, you know. And then he
um he this is like LA the LA area. He
moves away from LA. Years later he gets
a call from somebody who was like,
"Yeah, remember that guy?" Yeah. So he
was there for years. The church went
downhill and then one day one of the
church members was invited to go. I
don't know why they were there. They
were invited to go to a Catholic
service. I guess they knew somebody who
was like, "Would you come with me for
something?" So they go and they're like,
"Wait a minute. That's the same guy.
That's the priest was literally the same
guy doing the services on Sunday, but in
his old church that Scotty attended at
the time, he was also the pastor. Why
would that be? I mean, I don't know if
that was a Jesuit, but it sounds very
Jesuit to me. So, for people who are
saying this doesn't happen anymore and
like you're saying, they're in disguise.
Yeah. And somebody actually handwrote
over to the right there lacuna actually
clarifying what this book is from
because it doesn't actually bear his
name on it. But that's the that's the
kind of stuff that they did. And you
know here in the text you can see right
here some of this idea of futurism where
he talks about in such a way that the
resurrected ones and reigned with Christ
that is spoken of here are not only
beheaded or the martyrs but also
expressly those who did not worship the
beast his image uh nor take his
character on their foreheads or hands.
All of which is spoken of in this
chapter of revelation. speaking of
Revelation 13. But that it follows
evidently that the mystery of the first
resurrection of which we are speaking
must happen not before after the beast.
Then is a mystery neither that is
neither past nor present but very future
since the beast which is by their
confession interpreters is the
antichrist is yet to come. Mhm.
Futurism. Exactly. So this this future
antichrist. Now the sad reality is is
here we have some of these Protestants
who bought it. You've got Edward Irving
and you've got John Darby and they
helped translate this work by Lacuna to
English, bring it to the United States.
And you can see how it it seeped in.
Another individual who was involved here
was Margaret Margaret Macdonald, a
15-year-old Scottish girl, member of
Edward Irving's congregation, who had
these visions in 1830 that included a
secret rapture of believers before the
appearance of the Antichrist. She
informed Irving of her visions by letter
and attended the prophecy conferences
that begin in Dublin, Ireland in 1830 at
Powersport Castle, where he promoted
both futurism and a secret rapture. So
this is where the secret rapture comes
from that Christians believe. Yeah.
Yeah. So wait, these I I thought that
people Christians who believe in a
secret rapture, we're just studying the
Bible and we're like, "Okay, well this
is what it means. This is how we
interpret it." But that's the origin of
it. It's a person. All roads lead to
Rome. What? Well, and you know the the
the sad reality of this is is that
people don't realize that the devil is
just as capable of of offering false
signs and wonders that, you know, people
can get misled. And sadly, you know, we
have individuals like this who were, you
know, not testing these visions by the
Bible. Yeah. The Bible says by the law
and by the testimony. If they did not
speak according to these things, it's
because there is no light in them. They
you have to if you have visions and
dreams, which it is biblical to have
visions and dreams in the last days. It
does say that. But if you have them,
check them with the word of God. Doesn't
add up. It's not from the Lord. Well, we
all have a personal responsibility to
read and understand the scriptures for
ourselves. Exactly. Yeah. You know where
this uh thought content trickled down to
us? the Dallas Theological Seminary, a
non-denominational Protestant school.
You can see this uh filtering down their
prophetic esquetology. You got people
like Jan or or John uh Walvour, you got
Chuck Swindle, you got Charles Ryrie,
Vernon McGee, Kenneth Taylor, Tim Leah,
you know, the Moody Institute in
Chicago, the Moody Press. They're all,
you know, downstream taking these kinds
of views of the end times. Mhm. Tim
Lehei was involved with the what was
this these books called again? Um the
Left Behind series. Left Behind series.
Yeah. And by the way, um Dallas Jenkins
dad was involved with that. Dallas
Jenkins being the director of The
Chosen. Interesting fact. Yeah. You
know, and Jerry Fwell, of course,
Trinity Broadcasting Network, uh now I
think that's their now defunct center
there. But, um, they've had, you know,
two futurist themed movies, the Omega
Code and Megiddo. And uh you've got the
gathering, DRC Productions, uh End of
the Harvest, the Cristiano Film Group,
Jacqu Vanip Ministries and Jerry Fwell,
John HGY, all of these folks, Hilton
Sutton, uh Perry Stone, all all of these
folks teaching downstream these kinds of
theological positions, which again, Rome
has been very effective in taking the
heat off of her by either teaching
predism or futurism. Yeah, it doesn't
matter which one you buy, but if you can
take either one of those positions and
be blind to what's right in the middle,
Satan would love to people to be either
nearsighted or farsighted in Bible
prophecy and miss what's right before
them. Yeah. Again, predatorism being the
Antichrist has been in the past.
Futurism being it's in the future. And
all of this is literally Jesuit
doctrine. Yep. We are historicists. Mhm.
We're right smack in the middle and
recognizing the Antichrist power
directly where he ruled for 1260 years
for the beast that was not
uh or
was is not and yet is. You know,
Revelation talked about this power that
that was in the past rule 1260 years is
not and there's a time period where it
receives a deadly wound and no longer
has power but will return at the end of
time. And the problem is is that all of
these ministries do not recognize the
power that's going to return at the end
of time is exactly the power that ruled
in the past. And that's Roman
Catholicism. Yep. Well, and there was a
deadly wound, right? There's a deadly
wound that is is being healed. And that
deadly wound is the removal of state
power. They they have the religious
power, but the the state power got taken
away. Remember, they wanted to combine
the two. That's what we talked about on
the flag and everything is a combination
of political and state power. Yeah. And
it was removed during the French
Revolution, right? Yeah. This is all
history, right? But that power is being
given back to Rome in spades now with
Pope Francis. Oh, yeah. You can see him
speaking to the United Nations. He just
went to Belgium. And you can see him
speaking to the G7, which is all the
major economic countries that come
together to to talk the economy. What on
earth has the pope to do with the
economy? Like like you're a religious
person, right? And my question is, why
are we all looking at the pope? Why are
we not looking at some other pastor and
some other Christian individual? Why is
it just this guy? Because the Bible says
that they all wandered after the beast.
Wander with an A, meaning literally you
follow the guy. Y um so pretty
interesting. Yep. But it's a message
that we have to share. We have to tell
others about the great controversy about
the great controversy between Christ and
his angels and Satan and his angels.
Yep. And how that is going to play out
in the end. Yeah. And how we have to be
warned about it. We have to have an
understanding. Hey, we're coming close
to the mark of the beast. We're coming
close to the beast power coming back
having its wound healed according to
prophecy. And that's why we're sharing
this today. Again, this is not an attack
on beautiful Catholic people who are in
this system. But again, if they if we we
have to share the truth, we have to
share the truth in love because that's
what Jesus calls us to do to say, "Look,
this is what the Bible says. Let's
follow Jesus as he is telling us to in
the word because he is coming soon." If
you like this video, like, subscribe,
and hit the notification bell so you
know when we launch new videos. And drop
a comments below, and we'll try to get
back to you if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]